here's all we going to do I gave you
lots of clues do you remember I gave you
clues right I'm going to start to
approach it by first taking the idea of
similar triangles the first thing that
was mentioned I think the dimension it
was ratios but I can't get to ratios
can't say anything about ratios until I
say something about the similar
triangles first do you agree with that
okay so for starters what are the
similar triangles you can see them
before you prove them the D bdq and b FP
perfect so the first line I'm going to
say is in triangle bdq and triangle what
do we call it B FB I'm going to now
start to talk about some features so
excuse me I don't know enough about the
length yes to be able to say something
about these being a proportion because
remember I've measured these like it's
not precise enough it's not it isn't in
fact equal okay
so I'm going to instead appeal to angles
rather than sides okay there's a common
angle there's an angle that's in both
triangles which angle is that it's the
one right at the top f BP or of course
you could have called it DB q either of
them is fine I'm going to say DV q
that's a Q is common so you need to say
now in order to get towards equiangular
I only need two angles and I've already
got one okay so what would you like to
choose is the other one yes go ahead
Nick
wonderful so I'm mad to write that but
before I do that I want to point out
remember we've seen in the past we've
made a big deal about getting these
vertices their letters in order right we
want them to correspond in the correct
order one of the reasons why we do that
is not just so you don't get confused
but also whenever you're naming features
down here if these letters are in order
then you can just use them in the order
that they are okay
so if I had wanted to use the other
angles like say B QD P you see how I
would have just looked at this I would
say b QD i don't even need to look at
the diagram now if you look at the order
of the letters b QD will be b PF because
i thought about the letters in order and
sure enough b QD b PF it just matches up
because you thought about it first other
little minor point just have a look at
the way that I worded this okay
corresponding angles is never your way
to get around saying that maybe you said
parallel lines here that's fine I'm
totally okay with that I like to name
more specifically which features I'm
talking about because there's lots of
parallel lines here and I want to know
which relationship you're after it also
is a bit of a hack because it's not very
good grammar but it sounds it's horrible
grammar but it's actually more
descriptive because what it's saying is
corresponding angles on these lines that
are parallel which I say this way and it
is important to say this because you
guys know that there's another
relationship on of angles between
parallel lines that unequal what are
they come into your angles they're
supplementary so it's important that you
put that not just say corresponding
angles okay I've got a pair of angles
I've got another pair of angles
therefore and what was that reason again
just one word equiangular very good
yeah you don't need to prove a
Pettingill to is enough okay now here's
the tricky thing while we're getting and
all are talking about these intercepts
are four okay excuse me
BD BD is fine it's one of the sides of
one of the similar triangles that looks
good doesn't it but when you have a look
at DF you're in trouble a lot of you
went straight to DF because you are you
did what I've trained you to do which is
to have one eye on you're working on one
eye on your destination but you've gone
a little bit too far because look at DF
carefully let me highlight it for you
here is DF if you look carefully you
recognize DF is not a side in a triangle
do you notice that DF is not a sighted
trying to it's part of a side in a
triangle it's a side in a trapezium but
that's not very helpful to me right so
therefore you can't make a statement
about DF just yet on the basis of this
because DF has nothing to do with these
or at least I'm going to get needs of
legwork to get there okay now that I've
got my similar triangles I can now say
something about the ratios so what will
I do
AC and BD why don't have AC here I do
have something thats related to AC
though so that's what I'm going to
appeal to I'm going to say be cue on now
I've got to compare it to the
corresponding side in the similar
triangle what is the corresponding side
what corresponds to beat you in the big
triangle it's be patron P equals B D on
B F make sense little triangle big
triangle little triangle big trend
reason and you can't skip this
corresponding sides in similar triangles
are in proportion okay can I get a show
of hands how many people got to this
step 10 Bob strain uh smaller than I
expected
okay hands down all right we should have
been able to get to this step the
similar train was a kind of sitting
there staring you in the face in fact
the hardest part is not proving the
similar triangles because as you can see
it it's not that much work the hard part
is what comes next this is true we want
to get to here so how we're going to do
this ergo suggest something you can go
over to here is that what you say yep
yep okay so if you want I can get proms
on this be Q and B P which I'm actually
not really that interested that was just
the construction right I can go to the
sides that I was more interested in by
appealing to the fact that let's see
what am I going to say a C over a equals
this I've done a substitution and what's
the reason
what's your what property are you going
to appeal to does anyone else see it
before I go to air you know see what why
is this side equal to this side what
shape is this project isn't that's a
parallelogram right parallel parallel
and same deal here are the big one this
is a big parallelogram as well is that
okay so I can say that these are equal
because opposite sides in parallelograms
are equal
so that's a good step I've clearly
gotten closer to where I want to get to
because at least I've got a/c on it
now here comes a bit more of the
manipulation right we've got a E and B f
AE and bf but I want to get down to
their components these guys okay
well their components are clearly
related together how are they related
together
what is a e what's it made up of yeah
it's made up of two chunks right I can
write this as AC / AC plus C e do you
agree that's true isn't it and that's
clearly better because look it's got a C
inky in it and I want to see it so
that's progress that's good what about
the other side this is going to be I
don't want B F I'm going to write that
as B D plus D if you can see it country
okay and it doesn't need to be any
reasoning supplied because that's just
you know there are two sides that make
up that I'm learning our pause for a
moment because here you have the
opportunity to think and I'm giving you
a huge leg up into the question okay
do you reckon you could claw your way up
from here to our ending think carefully
give it a shot